-I was very jealous.
I heard that there was
a "SNL" children's talent show
-There sure was.
It was pretty delightful,
I got to say.
-[ Laughs ]
-I think it was --
I think it was
Tina's brainchild.
-Uh-huh.
-And then she got our older kids
to get together and plan it.
And as you can imagine,
it was -- It was pretty great.
-So this is mostly sort of
my era of women of "SNL"
and their children
doing a talent show on Zoom.
-Yeah, Tina Fey, Amy Poehler
Rachel Dratch, Ana Gasteyer,
Paula Pell, Emily Spivey,
and myself. And --
-And all four
of your children performed
-No, mine were feeling
a little shy that day.
My youngest two performed.
They claimed
that they had jokes,
which is always a little scary
because that's...
-Yeah, terrifying.
-...improvised.
But they just ended up
doing a lot of bickering
in costumes for a while.
I think my son was dressed
as a hamburger.
And he was bickering
with my daughter
who was holding a sword.
So, you know, stuff like that.
-Yeah.
-Pretty run of the mill.
-And you have a fair amoun
of wigs at your home, yes?
-Yes, of course.
-[ Laughs ]
I'm happy to hear that.
-You're one of our nation'
finest wig actors.
I don't think
you would argue that fact.
-I'm really grateful
to hold that moniker.
I personally love a wig.
I really love a wig. And I -
We did a Zoom birthday party
for our good friend
Paula Pell recently,
and the wigs,
the wigs came out flying.
-The wigs were flying?
-The wigs were flying, yeah.
I don't know --
I can't remember what
my character's name was anymore,
but at some point, I had -
What's the -- I had
a Merida wig on from "Brave.
-From "Brave," yeah.
-But it's so long and red
that I looked nude.
And then somehow we decide
that she was --
She was like Carole Baskin
but for dogs,
so she had a dog sanctuary
She was pretty hateable.
-Gotcha.
-She was really hateable.
-That's good. I see --
These are --
It's fun to do a talent show
and find new characters.
-Yeah, that's --
Listen, I got time, so that's --
That's what I do with my time.
-[ Laughs ]
I was wondering what you think
Have you watched
any of the "SNL At Home"?
Because I watched on Saturday.
And I found it so --
It's all so fascinating to me,
especially because there's a way
they're doing "SNL" now
that you and I
have never experienced.
Are you at all jealous
that you don't get --
I mean, again, it's for a ba
reason that they're doing it
but it does seem like
it's bringing out
some real creativity.
-I think it's lovely.
And I love the very first
episode for that.
I feel like it really held o
to that spirit --
It reminded me so much
of that spirit of when we worked
at the show.
-Yeah.
-You know, when we worked there,
it was after September 11th.
I remember having
to come into the writer's room
and figure out
what we were going to do
in light of what was going on.
I remember the day
that they said,
"Hey, there's anthrax
in the building,"
and we had a show that week.
And we lost our host,
and then our host came back.
I mean, these things all started
flooding back in my head
of, like, "Oh, yeah,
we kept working."
And there's a looseness
and a joy
and a goofiness
in those episodes.
And then -- And seeing Kenan
in a blanket as a costume
was like maybe my favorite
-Yeah, Kenan in a blanket'
always going to be a winner.
-It's the top of my list.
But I have to say, it's pretty
amazing to turn it on,
you know, the next time they d
"Saturday Night Live At Home,"
and people --
I mean, Brad Pitt playing Fauci.
I mean, it's beautiful.
It's all so beautiful,
everybody pitching in
and doing it --
seeing Tom Hanks host
that first week,
getting to meet people's cats,
it's -- it's beautiful.
It's the spirit of the sho
that I genuinely love the most
-Yeah, and I really have a ton
of respect
for what they're doing,
because like you said,
after 9/11, we were really lucky
to be together.
And the fact that
they're doing it apart
so that other people
can feel that closeness
is a really, really sweet,
great undertaking.
-It's -- Yeah.
-I heard another --
I believe this was,
again, the brainchild
of Tina Fey's children
that you adopted
is the themed quarantine party
dinner party.
-The themed dinner party
is the --
I mean, I was so impressed
with the initial idea.
Tina sent a video of her girls
putting together, like,
a themed airline dinner.
So, you have --
-How does this work?
-So, you have --
You have a flight attendant.
And the flight attendant
comes around --
Everyone's VIP.
Everyone gets moved
to first class.
-Gotcha. So you're just sittin
in chairs in the house.
-Sitting in chairs.
Everyone gets an iPad.
[ Both laugh ]
And everyone gets
their order taken.
And then your dinner's
brought to you.
And then you have an iPad
and possibly a glass of wine
and then you watch your show
and eat in silence.
-[ Laughs ]
-It was magical.
-And the kids love it.
-Oh, they loved it.
I've never seen a quieter dinner
in my house.
We actually didn't --
We didn't --
The kids --
The kids used the iPads.
We just sat and had
a really nice, quiet dinner.
But it was pretty awesome.
But, I mean, you know, my --
I have to say, there are so many
incredible ideas going aroun
on the Internet
and from other kids.
And I love the way
everyone's just --
just figuring day by day out
from that.
My kids are obsessed
with Disneyland.
So then, they decided to hav
a Disneyland themed dinner
one night. And we had --
They reenacted the rides.
And then, I guess
you can go on this site
where it takes you
through each ride,
and my kids acted out
the thing on "Cars"
where the cars were coming
and talking to us.
And then we got in the bathtub
at one point
and did Jungle Cruise.
It was --
-[ Laughs ]
-Well, I'm so happy to hea
how well you're
getting through this.
I'm so excited for everybody
to see "The Willoughbys."
And it is always
such a delight to talk to you.
-Thanks, Seth.
-Maya Rudolph.
-I love you. I hope you're well.
I hope --
I'm sending love to everybody.
Stay well.
-Alright, love from
our whole family to yours.
See you soon, Maya.
-Bye.